a week has passed since destiny has
released and you may be struggling to
get better gear but here are a few spots
you can farm to hopefully get you some
Legendary's the first spot is on the
moon and the mission is a dark beyond
make sure to choose the level 9
difficulty follows dinklebot until you
reach the dead guardian which will thank
you a cutscene the doors of the temple
of crota will open and you will be
swarmed by the hive make sure to consume
black wax if you have this as it will
receive extra glimmer from killing the
hive creatures kill as many other hive
as you can and make sure to focus on the
hallowed acolytes as they are worth a
good amount of glimmer in addition make
sure to pick up silken codex which will
give you 200 glimmer on turning a key
tip on this run is to not kill the
hallowed Knight as it will cause the
endless wave of pipe to stop also you
need them to kill you so that you can
repeat the area over and over keep
killing the swarming hive to earn up to
a hundred plus glimmer per run as well
as many engrams more on what to do with
glimmer later on in this video if this
part isn't doing it for you there's
another quest on the moon called the
shrine of Oryx make sure to choose the
level 12 difficulty the shrine of Oryx
has two different areas where you can
farm that will give you 250 plus glimmer
per run and will give you the added
bonus of many silk and codex drops
follow dinklebot until you reach the
halls of wisdom here you are running to
chosen knights chosen acolytes and some
dregs that are fighting just beyond that
are hollowed acolytes and a hollowed
wizard kill them all jump into the abyss
and then repeat the area over and over
again until you've maxed out on
glimmering again make sure to use black
wax for more glimmer output if you get
bored of the halls of wisdom you can go
further into the shrine of Oryx here
you'll find some dregs and hallowed
acolytes battling it out after you've
proceeded to kill that eight hallowed
acolytes you'll find that there's
actually a hallowed ogre in here as well
after dealing with the hallowed odor and
some stray hive make a run and jump into
the lava and repeat the area again make
sure to consume the black wax again as
it'll buff your glimmer output again
kill die loot rinse and repeat now to
talk about what to do with all that
sweet glimmer you farmed go to the crypt
dark and turn in any of the Silk'n codex
you have and
code any blue or legendary engrams you
found if you found a legendary hold your
breath
cross your fingers and hope you get a
legendary well that didn't quite worked
out but now we try strategy number two
take your glimmer and purchase the green
items from the Crypt art until you run
out of glimmer the hope is that you're
able to level your crypt dark which will
then reward you with a present from the
crypt dark at the postmaster this
package can have up to three Legendary's
in it or sometimes none at all however
chances are you'll at least get one here
we got one so let's hold our breath
cross our fingers and boom goes the
dynamite we got one good luck farming
the crypt dark isn't as bad of a guy as
the internet makes them out to be
you